you know
in sports you in boxing you see a george
foreman get knocked out by muhammad ali
nobody thought it was going to happen he
went into depression a couple years
you saw sugar ray leonard go against
roberto duran and
you know he beat him psychologically and
physically he was in depression for a
couple years
you see it happening in sports where
somebody goes to the finals or
world series or super bowl and it's a
very
you know traumatic loss public loss
sometimes they don't get over it
what did the 2017 event do to you
when your family was doing the uh the
you guys call it the pyramid walk i
believe with eight of you you can
highlight what that means and there was
an accident
and where you know most people fell
except for three of you i believe that
didn't fall and you were able to hold on
what did that do to you and how were you
able to recover from that single event
that happened to your family
yeah so we were training for about six
weeks here in
in florida in my backyard for that eight
person pyramid and
uh everything went pretty good we were
we were doing well we started two feet
went up 10 feet
went up 15 feet and then decided we were
going to go up to the height to break
that world record
which was for this four layer eight
person pyramid 28 feet above the ground
and uh basically what it is is four
people standing on the wire two people
on their shoulders
and then a person on their shoulders and
then a person stacked on a fourth layer
on top of that so
the top person being my aunt was about
50 feet above the ground
at the apex of that pyramid and as we
made our way out in a rehearsal at full
height it was the second time we were
doing it up
at full height the next day we were
premiering it for guinness and
in front of a live audience that was
when my worst nightmare became a reality
we were walking our way out on the wire
and uh not sure what happened lost our
balance
my five of my family members and friends
fell to the ground
and as you mentioned i caught the wire
my cousin caught the wire and one other
gentleman stayed standing
but the other five hit the ground
statistics say 30
chance of living from a fall of that
height or greater without any safety
devices
my sister not only fell but she fell on
her head she broke every bone in her
face
she has 73 screws and plates in her face
alone at this point
uh was in a coma internal bleeding a lot
of broken bones my aunt a couple other
guys hurt pretty bad
and i remember sitting in the hospital
the day after that accident
and in the waiting room not knowing
whether people are going to be able to
walk anymore
not knowing whether my sister was going
to live we knew the other four were
were going to live but they weren't out
of the woods yet and
i remember sitting there and my dad
looking at me and saying hey you're
supposed to speak at emily arena in
tampa to
a corporation tomorrow he said what are
you gonna do and i said dad i don't even
know i i
i mean it never walked the wire again
and it wasn't fear at that point in any
way it was
it was the fact that i didn't want to
disrespect
those that had fallen and i thought you
know are they how are they going to look
at me i
certainly had survivors guilt at that
point i felt horrible that i wasn't in a
hospital that i couldn't
trade places with any one of them and my
dad looked at me and he said well if
you're going to do it i'll be there for
you he said i'll make sure your rigging
is safe and i'll make sure it goes off
without a hitch
i've got your back and and i get
goosebumps when i say that because here
his baby girl his only daughter
may not live but he supports his son to
the point where rather than being bitter
he says
i'm there for you i got your back and i
remember
i remember going you know what that
thinking back to my great-grandfather
the legacy
him going back to the wire the day after
that accident and saying
you're right this is what our family
does i said but i'm going to take it a
step further i'm gonna go visit the
other four that are in the hospital and
talk to the other two the other two that
stayed and caught the wire
couldn't talk to my sister at that point
and get their blessing and i did that i
made the rounds through the hospital
and said what is your opinion every one
of them looked at me and said
you have to do it get back on the wire
so i did i got back on the wire the next
day
i performed in fact for the next five
weeks straight with only four days off
all the while my sister still in the
hospital and in the process of
recovering at that point
and after that five weeks i took six
weeks off and then we headed to new york
city where i was headlining on a new
show
where we were going to perform the seven
person pyramids so very similar to that
pyramid
mat in fact uh peripherally the same as
as that eight-person pyramid for me so
uh we started training and i started
visualizing that that pyramid falling in
front of me on the wire
and after about a week of that i started
to physically tremble on the wire
something i'd never experienced in my
life in fact
the emotion of fear i didn't even think
existed my dna certainly for walking the
wire
and i remember going through that
process and and after a week of that
going to my wife and saying do you do
you know what's going on in the pyramid
are you watching this and she goes yeah
i said well who's shaking
and the reason i ask that is as the
leader of that pyramid for for years
i've done it thousands of times
i would there's always somebody who has
jitters early on and when they shake you
feel them you're all connected together
and she looked at and she said what do
you mean i was like who's shaking she
goes it's you.
and i thought there's no way it can't be
me i i was still denying the fact that i
was dealing with fear at that point
and uh i said uh well i'm gonna get back
in the wire and see if i can work
through this couple days later one of my
guys in my troop who's been with me my
whole life grabs me
literally grabs me after rehearsal and
shakes me and he goes what the hell is
wrong with you
i was like what do you mean what's wrong
with me thinking that they didn't know
what was going on they can't see me
they're all in front of me
or on top and he says you're shaking
like crazy what is going on with you
this isn't the nik wallenda that we've
all
looked up to that that drives us to
greatness this is not the guy who we've
respected
and at that point what happened was hey
i had to admit that i was fearful
but at that point i was dealing with
shame the the fact that here i
am the the you know the greatest wire
walker of our generation
i'm fearless and i'm not fearless and
people are realizing this
and people are recognizing this and at
that point
i had to actually back up further and
deal with the the pride that led to
shame the pride that i was too good to
be fearful
deal with the shame and then dig down to
the root of what fear actually was
and then then work through that fear it
got to the point where i told my wife
one evening i said i'm done i'm not
getting back on the wire ever again i'm
done
and i remember that conversation like it
was right now and my wife looked at me
now mind you my wife comes from eight
generations of circus on one side seven
of the o
of the other she has two guinness world
records herself she's an amazing
aerialist and daredevil and and she
supports me because of that and that's
how she can understand
my passion for doing these things and
she looked at me and she said
for 200 years your family have lived by
the words never give up
the show must go on that's the way
you've lived you do what you do
all the time you're inspiring people
that nothing's impossible and you're
gonna give up because of something in
your head
she goes nah that's not you you're not
gonna give up and i remember sitting
back feeling defeated literally
sitting back in the couch and tears
rolling down my face like i'm defeated
i changed two laws in two countries i
walked across some of the craziest
places in the world without safety
devices
risking my life and this small
four-letter word
fear is is going to ruin the rest of my
career and possibly my life
and i started going down this route of
depression and as i started going down
that that path which many people do
i remember um just sitting there i
always reflect on my great grandfather
and his
book and his stories that i've been told
and the videos i've watched and
the tapes that i've listened to and i
thought you know what this isn't what my
family does i'm not going to go down
this path
and my mind was deep it was in the
gutter at that point i was in the valley
and i remember thinking you know what
everything my great-grandfather did
he was able to overcome and he was able
to prove that the impossible was
possible
and even though this feels impossible
i'm going to overcome it and when i
overcome it i'm going to write about it
i'm going to tell the story and i'm
going to use this so other people that
are dealing with fear
don't have to go so down deep into that
valley like i did and don't have to go
into that deep depression
and that's when i set off on this
journey of of going and really it was it
was about stepping out
and going okay how were you raised what
were you taught and and what are you
doing differently now
and and it really came down to the power
of the mind and where i allowed my mind
to go
and controlling those thoughts and and
drowning out that negativity
and continually focus on positive rather
than thinking you're gonna fall while
you're holding this pyramid i would
think
you've held it more than anyone in the
world successfully thousands of times
you've held this pyramid
one accident and you're gonna focus on
the one not the thousands
and i started just telling myself that
and working through this process and
and again with the help of psychologists
and psychiatrists and spending time with
people
that really could teach me to to
re-learn
who i was and re-learn how i do and have
done what i do
[Music]
you